Hey, Youtubers! It's Charlie. So they just posted the Oscar nominees, so I thought it would be fun to do a reaction video.
Generally I don't think of the Oscars too seriously, i don't take it too seriously.
I think of it more of a reminder of all the awesome movies that I did not see during the year.
Like the whole list of nominees is just judging me for not having seen them.
There are a lot of movies that got nominated, so I'll mention a couple of really important ones that I think you should check out in case you missed them too.
We should say up front though The Oscars, all awards shows in general. Complete bullshit.
They're not so much to recognize talent as they are to get television advertising. So if a movie you really liked didn't get nominated don't freak out. The way people vote on the nominees is ridiculous.
There is actually a really good Mental Floss article that describes in in great detail, like in excruciating detail. So I will add the link in the description.
There is also this episode of South Park, the Funny Bot episode that explains it in beautiful describes the way you should feel about award shows.
It's all about the speech that Funny Bot has at the end. Like they defeat him with the logic problem by giving him a Comedy Award in recognition of his achievement.
It's such a perfect speech. I will just play the audio right here.
"For what purpose is Comedy Award?" "It's a validation of all your effort, an acknowledgment of all you do in the pursuit of you."
"Non sequitur, there is no logic in Comedy Award, unable to process. If I accept it means i take comedy seriously, If I take comedy seriously, I am not comedian non sequitur must analyze!"
So yea, that's the perfect way to think about award shows in your head. It's not just Comedy Awards, it's all award shows in general.
So my big reactions. Totally not surprised about Birdman and Michael Keaton being at the top of the mentions. Birdman (Best Picture) Michael Keaton (Best Actor).
I know I didn't do a review for it but it's one of the best small movies of the year.
I think Guardians Of The Galaxy was probably my favorite big movie.
I try not to lump every thing together when I get super judgy about movies and tv. Just because some things are just made for very specific audiences and award shows are made to be very broad.
I think the biggest bummer is The Lego Movie got totally got snubbed.
One of the directors, Phil Lord posted this picture on Twitter, probably my favorite reaction. This is probably like the best Oscars reaction.
There was some backlash over Selma being snubbed over the Best Actor category. David Oyelowo played Martin Luther King Jr. He had this amazing performance.
He's actually on Star Wars Rebels, he plays this character. This is probably who a lot of you know him as.
People were complaining that the Oscars had been white-washed. I feel like that's a problem that's endemic to Hollywood films in general.
So it's not a new problem. This happens all the time.
So here is like the cliffs notes for the movies that you really have to see. That are really gonna be talked about a lot at the Oscars.
First off is Birdman. Really funny, really dark it totally makes fun of Michael Keaton's Batman films. They even made this parody ad that REALLY layed into the trailer of Batman Forever.
"In a world of darkness, in a time of chaos. the only hope to save a city is a hero who flys in the face of evil. 1992 is the year of The Bird.......man. "That's what I'm talkin' about!" Riggan Thompson in Birdman Returns."
That was the movie that made Michael Keaton leave the Batman franchise. He saw the script and was like "This Blows, Peace I'm outta here, see'ya".
Foxcatcher, another super intense, super dark story with Channing Tatum and Steve Carrel and The Hulk (Mark Ruffalo). Steve Carrel is up for best actor and Mark Ruffalo is up for best supporting actor.
I always like checking out The Avengers whenever they do small, interesting movies. So if you ever wondered why there is so much talk about them getting tired of playing big characters. Like why Mark Ruffalo doesn't talk about The Hulk all the time. I mean people ask him about The Hulk all the time. but usually he likes to talk about his other stuff.
It's mostly because the small stuff they do allows them WAYYY more creative freedom. They get a lot more authorship. Every once in a while like everything comes together in a really amazing way you get a Birdman or a Foxcatcher.
Those are two extreme examples of like really small movies that like ended up being as fun as a big comic book movie.
So moving down the list. So I'm assuming that everybody saw The Lego Movie like two or three times or maybe even four than bought it on DVD.
So we're good on that one.
If you missed Ben Affleck in David Fincher's "Gone Girl" That's totally ok. It's a really weird movie. People are going to be talking about it a lot but if you want a good barometer for Ben Affleck in Batman V. Superman I think a better movie with him to see is probably The Town.
Which he starred in with Hawkeye. That's actually the movie that Jeremy Renner earned the role of Hawkeye in The Avengers by the way.
David Fincher and Ben Affleck are actually re-teaming up this year, like the same production team to do a new version of Alfred Hitchcocks's Strangers On A Train. I'm more excited about then I am for Gone Girl.
There were a ton of great animated films that were nominated. Studio Ghibli's last big film, Princess Kaguya, that's something that you absolutely need to check out. Just on principle. I mean it's a good movie too, it's an amazing movie.
Just looking at the sales figures I'm assuming that everybody also saw How To Train Your Dragon 2 and Big Hero 6.
I'm behind on Boxtrolls I actually still haven't seen that yet too. But you guys need to see that.
Everyone totally saw Guardians Of The Galaxy so no need to worry about that.
It was one of the true comic book movies that got nominated. It was in the makeup and VFX categories
Comic book movies in general usually only win awards for technical achievements. Even Christopher Nolan got snubbed for all of the time for his Batman films.
Critically the ones that do stand out are the ones that look and feel VERY different, very unique. That's actually one of the reasons why I like Guardians Of The Galaxy more than Winter Soldier.
Plus I have a bias for space opera that I am totally willing to admit...
Here's my big question for you guys. You know scanning the list of all the nominees which of your favorite movies actually made the list?
I'll actually add a link to my Tumblr with like a full breakdown of the list in case you have not seen the nominees yet.
I'm not planning on doing any big Oscar videos but  I will consider it. So if you guys really want some Oscar stuff I will try to do some when they actually do the awards.
I am working on Game Of Thrones and Star Wars for tomorrow. New Game Of Thrones, New Star Wars coming. Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I know that everybody is talking about Suicide Squad this morning because Tom Hardy left. He was playing the Rick Flagg character.
I'm sure some where in the distance Jake Gyllenhaal's phone is ringing off the hook, David Ayer, doing Suicide Squad. He also directed End Of Watch which Jake Gyllenhaal was the star of.
So I am assuming that he is on David Ayer's short list. And when you look at him he looks like a good stand in for Tom Hardy anyways, physically.
Right now, in case you haven't seen it here is my Avengers Age Of Ultron QnA from yesterday I just answered who some of the mystery characters are. and you can click here to get ready for Arrow and The Flash which come back next week.
So thanks so much for watching let's High Five and see you tomorrow!